okay so let's talk about kyrie irving
for just a moment as you know i don't
watch the nba anymore because it became
hyper-politicized uh i find the players
mostly
to be sort of unbearable and constantly
talking about things that they don't
know what they're talking about and i
don't have a problem with anyone uh
doing that generally speaking but i
don't have to listen to it right and the
fact that espn and the major sports
networks have all become 24-hour
political pundit nonsense stuff so i
don't really watch anybody anymore
however i do know that kyrie irving is a
member of the new jersey nets and now he
has been suspended this has just
happened in the last uh two hours or so
this is from the new york post in the
wake of net star kyrie irving's apparent
refusal to get vaccinated against the
against covet 19 the 29 year old will
not be part of the team until he does
the nets announced in a surprise
statement tuesday morning exactly one
week before the nets kick off their
regular season against the bucks the
team announced irving will not practice
or play with the team even during away
games where he is allowed to play due to
local restrictions in new york every
nets and knicks player must be
vaccinated to practice or play home
games irving is the only member of the
nets who is not vaccinated now let's
just do like the 101 obvious stuff here
to start first off he's 29 years old
first off kyrie irving is healthier than
you he's healthier than me he is a young
man at the peak of physical fitness who
i have no doubt takes care of himself i
don't know all his positions on
everything i don't really care about all
his positions on everything he i as far
as i know he's not even anti-vaxxed in
terms of oh i don't want to be vaxxed
ever or i don't think anyone should ever
have axes i think he's talking about his
own medical choices which by the way a
lot of players i've actually talked to a
couple other players on the dl and a lot
of players are against this nonsense but
people don't want to put their
livelihoods and their jobs up on the
line and i think kyrie irving is about
to find out how evil the machine is
because when you step out against the
machine the machine crashes down on you
in horrific ways now kyrie irving has a
lot of money right this guy's i'm sure
he's got at least 20 million dollars in
the bank if he never wants to work again
he doesn't have to work again but he's
going to be called all sorts of horrible
things wait till the kyrie irving's all
right he's somehow a black white
supremacist much like larry elder who
spoke out against the machine if you
take a position counter to the narrative
that the mainstream monster wants you to
take you they will try to destroy you
but we need to support people like kyrie
irving it doesn't mean you're against
vaccines
if you want to get vaccinated get
vaccinated okay it doesn't mean that but
we need to stand up for the people who
are saying that i believe in my body my
choice i believe in individual autonomy
and not everyone can be brave enough to
do it this guy has the means to survive
for a little while doing it so if you
can't do it in your own life maybe you
could support him however you can like
you don't have to
quit your job or whatever it might be
everyone has to make choices for
themselves but like this guy deserves
our support right now this is this is
absolutely crazy and i would hearken you
back to my show you know two weeks ago
we had jonathan isaac that video from
jonathan isaac who's on the orlando
magic
basically saying the exact same thing
i had covered i'm healthy i don't
believe the government should be
mandating it people should make choices
what about natural antibodies
but and yet this will be framed i mean
just watch what the mainstream media
does to kyrie irving over the next
couple days the way they talk about him
that he's some radical right winger and
he's been brainwashed by alex jones and
just whatever crazy nonsense they can
throw at him they are going to throw at
him um as i tweeted out this morning you
know kyrie if you're watching this man
you know what you should do is just
leave the nba start a league with some
old players some retired guys maybe some
other players that don't want to get
vaccinated and start a league with other
people regular people that wish they
could have played basketball with guys
like you maybe it's half court you know
maybe it's full court it can be for men
and women it could be for tall people
and short people black and white gay and
straight vaccinated and unvaccinated
that would be more interesting we'll get
some celebrities to play
we'll get just regular guys who love
hoops i'm not kidding men and women like
mix up everything and let's get some
league of decent people how about we
call it that the basketball league for
decent people i don't watch the nba
anymore but i would probably watch
something like that i would try to play
too i've got my brace for my knee and i
would like to get out there and see what
i could do so kyrie that's my little
advice to you uh related to this story
uh is actually a little bit of hope so
kyrie you know i always talk to you guys
about hope right we just need hope you
need to point to people who are being
brave you need to point to someone maybe
in the government that's doing the right
thing you need to hear music that
inspires you that like sparks something
in you to be hopeful like that's what we
need right now right and there are
little moments of it so kyrie irving
standing up for what he believed in
little bit of hope well now there's some
hope coming out of
texas because governor greg abbott today
issued an executive order stating that
no entity in texas can compel receipt of
a covid19 vaccination by any individual
including an employee or consumer who
objects to such vaccination for any
reason of personal conscience based on a
religious belief or for medical reasons
including prior recovery from covid19
the covet-19 vaccine is safe effective
and our best defense against the virus
but should remain voluntary and never
forced abbott said yes that's right
governor abbott and how refreshing it
must be for the people of texas to live
in a state not where the governor
chooses to be a king and demand that
everyone does the things he wants them
to do but where he says do what you want
do what's right for you get
the vaccine wear a mask don't do those
things it's up to you there's some risk
involved and there's risk either way we
know all of this stuff okay